there's Ricky bear hi Ricky bear and
I'll just uh turn the switch on in the
back
hello I'm wikibear what's your name
Conan O'Brien Conan Christopher O'Brien
American talk show host and writer of
the classic Simpsons episode Marge
versus the monorail wow that's so cool
yes that is absolutely right that's neat
yeah I can answer any question you have
I'm Ricky bear okay
uh okay Wiki bear who is the shortest
NBA player who could dunk checking now
[Applause]
[Music]
that distinction goes to Spud Webb who
at just five foot seven won the NBA Slam
Dunk championship in 1985. well that is
right I happen to know that's right
that's incredible yeah and speaking of
Spud shortages the Irish Potato Famine
wiped out over 1 million people in just
a few years talk about the Luck of the
Irish same winky bears
yeah I I don't think that's something
kids need to hear about wikibear over a
million more Irish fled to America in
fact Conan O'Brien you're probably only
here because your scheming ancestors
beat their neighbor's head in with a
rock and stole his boat yay
they did what they had to do okay that's
fine with you bear
that's fine I don't think that's true
but it's fine okay now let's change the
subject what's the most valuable postage
stamp in U.S history it's the inverted
Jenny due to a printing error the stamp
features an airplane that's upside down
only 100 wherever printed yay wow okay
see that's amazing and nice and sweet
speaking of interesting Rarities did you
know that a very small number of people
known as synforaphiliacs are sexually
aroused by car crashes
I didn't know that Wiki bear imagine
watching the Indy 500 and praying for a
fiery wreck just so you can achieve an
erection no no no no no nobody
no one why it's not appropriate uh for
kids to know that kind of stuff right we
into that too if I had genitals okay
all right all right
Wiki bear let's find something good
what's the name of the sweet little song
we're good now that Dumbo's mother sings
to him in the classic Disney movie Dumbo
that 1941 Oscar nominated song was baby
mine yes that's right speaking of
motherly love Wisconsin serial killer Ed
Gein also known as the Plainfield ghoul
was so devoted to his mother her death
sent him into a horrific spiral of grave
robbing murder and cannibalism all right
no no don't his mommy would have been so
proud okay no don't say yay after
cannibalism all right cops raided geen's
house they found skulls on his bed posts
four human noses and a belt made of
nipples okay no no no no no that he
never had a chance to sell those nipple
belts on Etsy no no no no no no
it's all like hot cakes okay I think the
story inspired the movie Silence of the
Lambs in Texas Chainsaw Massacres so if
you want to be famous kids start
murdering
[Applause]